thank you it's a pleasure to be here
welcome all of you to New York I would
second the comment that there's an apple
ample supply of caffeine and sugar right
next door which you may need especially
right after lunch on a day after you you
came here so and I would also encourage
all of you to raise your hands and if
you have questions or you wanted me to
slow down or speed up or something like
that just just let me know i'd like to
make this as interactive as possible my
plan is to talk about four things this
afternoon first the status of us climate
regulation as it relates to the electric
power industry the second is new
developments in environmental regulation
other than climate change as it affects
the electric power industry third I'm
going to talk about some recent
developments at the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission and finally some
legal issues concerning related energy
matters so starting with the status of
us climate regulation in January of 2009
when barack obama was inaugurated
president there was widespread thought
that the u.s. was about to adopt
comprehensive climate legislation obama
had supported that during the
presidential campaign and so had his
opponent John McCain the Republican
candidate both of them had come out in
favor of a cap-and-trade bill the
president the new president did direct
EPA to go forward with its existing
regulatory authority under the Clean Air
Act but everyone I'm sorry EPA is the
Environmental Protection Agency but
thank you for pointing that out so the
president did ask the Environmental
Protection Agency to go forward with its
existing authority but that was just a
next up most people recognize that the
existing authority under our Clean Air
Act was not ideal for this purpose it
wasn't really set up for that when it
was enacted in 1970 and we and we really
wanted a new law so EPA went forward
with that but people didn't pay much
attention to it in June of 2009 the US
House of Representatives passed a bill
called the waxman-markey bill which was
a comprehensive economy-wide greenhouse
gas control law that included a
cap-and-trade program it then went to
the United States Senate because of
course for a bill to become law in the
u.s. it has to pass both the House and
the Senate and be signed by the
president when the bill went to the
Senate it basically died it was
supported by a few senators there was
one republic that the Democrats mostly
supported it but they didn't have enough
votes just among the Democrats to pass
there was one Republican senator named
lindsey graham from south carolina who
supported it for a while but then he
withdrew and the the bill died President
Obama had hoped to go to the next annual
united nations climate negotiation which
was taking place in Copenhagen in
December of 2009 with a mandate from
Congress he was not able to do that he
did not have that mandate from Congress
and so not a great deal happened in in
Copenhagen in November of 2010 in the US
federal election the Republicans took
over the US House of Representatives and
a majority of of the
new members of the House of
Representatives are opposed to any kind
of climate legislation it's quite clear
now that at least between now and the
next US federal election which is
November of 2012 we will not have
climate legislation it cannot because
the house of representatives will not
pass it their leadership has made that
quite clear what happens after that will
depend almost entirely on what happens
in the november two thousand twelve
election whether the which party
controls the house which party controls
the senate which party controls the
white house because president obama is
also up for re-election next year so
that means that the US is unable for at
least until the end of next year to
commit internationally to binding
emissions limitations and the US is
unable to to really sign on to an
extension of the Kyoto Protocol or any
of the other things that are under
negotiation President Obama does not
have to support he needs in Congress to
go forward with that I think that does
have the overall effect of meaning that
the UN climate negotiations such as the
next annual conference which is taking
place in Durban South Africa toward the
end of this year will talk about a
number of technical issues but that the
the larger issues of extension of the
Kyoto Protocol and many other issues are
probably going to be put off for some
time meanwhile there are active efforts
by some in Congress to cancel the
authority that the president now has the
Clean Air Act of 1970 is the basis for
the action going forward and there are a
number of bills introduced in the House
of Representatives and several of them
have passed the house that would either
repeal that authority or say that EPA
does not have the budget to carry it out
none of those bills have passed the
Senate and they probably won't but there
are still efforts to stop the action
through the appropriations process that
gives EPA the money that it that it
needs so meanwhile EPA is going forward
with its regulation under the Clean Air
Act the first important question was
whether greenhouse gases can be
regulated under the under the Clean Air
Act that statute our overall air
pollution law was really aimed at
conventional air pollutants carbon
monoxide and sulfur dioxide and
particulate matter and so forth the
administration of President Clinton in
the 1990s said yes it was subject to
regulation but they did not do anything
to use that authority president george w
bush said no it's not regulated a
lawsuit was brought by several states
and other organizations and in 2007 the
United States Supreme Court issued a
landmark decision in a case called
Massachusetts vs. EPA saying yes the
Clean Air Act does allow regulation of
greenhouse gases President Bush did not
do much with that authority but when
President Obama took office in January
2009 he did the first action was
something called an endangerment finding
it was a formal finding a declaration by
the EPA that greenhouse gases do cause a
danger to health and the in
ironmen the next step after that and
they did that in 2009 they then needed
to come up with a set of regulations and
they have been coming out with these
regulations over the last year and a
half and the most one set of the
regulations concerned fuel economy
standards and greenhouse gas emission
standards for automobiles that was
issued that was agreed upon by the
Automobile Manufacturers so that's going
forward the next are the regulations for
stationary sources for factories and
power plants and other stationary
sources of air pollution EPA is now
coming out with those rules one of the
important most important sets of of
those rules are called new source
performance standards these are
technical standards for the allowable
emissions from different sources of air
pollution one of the most important
sources of course is electric power
plants the largest single source of
greenhouse gas emissions in the United
States is coal-fired power plants and so
a regulation of those has become an
extremely important issue EPA was taking
more time to come up with these
standards than some in the environmental
community wanted it to take and so they
started a lawsuit to try to put EPA
under a deadline and that is a very
typical situation with us environmental
laws EPA takes a long time and people
sue them to try to speed them up and
they end up reaching an agreement on a
new schedule so that is a very common
kind of event that happened here and the
deadline for the
new source performance standards for
utility boilers was June of 2011 so they
were supposed to come out this past June
and then they were extended till the end
of September to just you know a few days
ago and then EPA said they still need
more time and they didn't announce when
they are going to come out with their
new standards they are being sued again
and so we'll go back and forth and again
there's this typical pattern so we don't
know when EPA is going to come out with
these standards for the allowable
greenhouse gas emissions from from new
power plants so that's that's one set of
rules another set of standards are what
is called best available control
technology bact that and those are
issued by the states since much of the
environmental regulation in the US is
carried out by the states acting under a
federal mandate so the states come out
with that that's still in the early
stages so far it looks like many of the
requirements with respect to greenhouse
gases will require energy efficiency
measures since there's no technology yet
to control greenhouse gas emissions
directly many of the utilities will
probably be required to spend more money
on energy efficiency to reduce the
amount of electricity they generate and
therefore the amount of greenhouse gases
EPA is not requiring them to change
fuels clearly one of the major ways that
greenhouse gases could be reduced is by
switching from coal to natural gas where
that is physically possible and where
there is a fuel supply but the EPA in
the states are not requiring that at
at this time meanwhile Congress again is
trying to stop EPA from doing any of
this and there are many lawsuits that
have been brought by industry against
EPA trying to say that these regulations
violate various laws in a number of ways
some of the challenges are based on
procedural issues some of them are based
on the wording of the Clean Air Act
there are more than 100 lawsuits that
have been brought against EPA by
industry and by those states that are
opposed to this kind of regulation many
of the states favor this kind of
regulation but many of the states oppose
it this is the leading state the one
that has been the most active in
opposing the regulations is Texas the
state that has been most active in
supporting the regulations is California
and lots of other states are different
places along the spectrum so these cases
have all been combined their pending
before the united states court of
appeals for the district of columbia
circuit let me just pause one minute and
the way that the US federal court system
is set up we have the United States
Supreme Court on top and then below that
are 10 intermediate courts called the
courts of appeals and they're based on
geography so it's the Court of Appeals
for the District of Columbia Circuit
that's hearing this case and below that
are the district courts which are the
trial level courts so these cases are
pending before the appellate court in
washington DC and it will hear argument
we think sometime in early 2012 and
we'll decide maybe may or june of 2012
and they might say that all the
regulations are fine they might say that
they're all invalid and throw them out
it might say they're mostly all right
but there are some defects but meanwhile
even though the litigation is pending
EPA has not been stopped from doing what
it's doing industry made an effort to
try to stop them getting an injunction
that was refused so ETA is going forward
with these actions so that's what's
happening under the Clean Air Act there
are things happening under other
regulations as well a in a different law
Congress several years ago established
what is called the greenhouse gas
reporting program which requires major
facilities to monitor for their
greenhouse gas emissions monitor the
amounts of greenhouse gases and then to
report those numbers to EPA that
monitoring was required to begin in
January of 2010 the reports needed to be
filed with EPA it was just two weeks ago
on September 30 of 2011 with the
deadline for filing all this information
with EPA EPA is now entering all of that
information on its computers and in a
few months will publicly release
summaries of it including statements
about who or what companies and what
facilities are the largest emitters of
greenhouse gases in the United States
this is similar to a program that has
been in existence for almost 20 years
called a toxic release inventory for
releases of other kinds of chemicals but
we'll see this information coming out
another important US Environmental Law
is the national environmental policy act
nepa that is the law that requires the
preparation of environmental impact
statements for major federal actions
that law has been around since 1970 but
now the courts have said that one of the
things that should be discussed in an
environmental impact statement under
this law is the effect of the project on
greenhouse gas emissions and also the
effect of climate change itself on a
project so we are now seeing for the
first time these environmental impact
statements being released that have some
of these numbers and some of these
projections another important law along
these lines is the the laws on
disclosure on securities violence so the
Securities and Exchange Commission is
now requiring that the financial
statements from publicly traded
companies have certain information about
whether the company is going to be
affected by greenhouse gas regulations
and and liability and also whether
climate change itself can have an effect
on the company so that's a new
requirement as well and companies are
only now figuring out how exactly what
to do there's also a great deal of
activity at the state level as I said
California is the leading state in terms
of regulating greenhouse gases on its
own us environmental law typically says
that states are free to impose
regulations that are more stringent than
the federal government they cannot be
less stringent
but they may be more stringent there are
some exceptions to that but for the most
part that's the rule so in 2007 governor
arnold schwarzenegger signed a law in
california called a be 32 and it's
california's greenhouse gas law under
that law california next year is
starting up its own cap-and-trade
program and so major sources of
greenhouse gas emissions in california
are going to need to buy allowances that
too to emit of greenhouse gases of
course under the european emissions
trading system you've had a
cap-and-trade program for some time but
here this is based on the california
will have its own there's there's
another existing law in the US that
already has a cap-and-trade program and
that's called the Regional Greenhouse
Gas Initiative called Reggie RGGI it
covers it covered ten states in the
northeastern united states including New
York and New Jersey but the Governor of
New Jersey chris Christie just took New
Jersey out of the program so it now has
nine states but Reggie is a
cap-and-trade program in these states it
only applies to carbon dioxide emissions
and it only applies to power plants of
more than 25 megawatts of capacity so
it's been operating about two years when
it was set up they they gave away a
large number they provided for a large
number of allowances allowed a large
quantity of carbon dioxide to be emitted
and it turned out they allowed too much
it's similar to what happened in some of
the
beginning years of the European
emissions trading system and as a result
of that sorry and as a result of that
the price is very low and so the the
price of allowance is so low that it is
not really having much effect on
emissions but it is generating a lot of
money that the states have did you ever
which is important for all of us I think
we have a hard time understanding how
the levels of regulation interact in
such a way that things that happen or
seem to be for us cause higher priority
would be developed at a lower level of
regulation or a state level that's going
to think and I think I mean I'd like to
have you you know that for us Europeans
you always have a hard time
understanding that regulation loss would
start by the lower level of the United
States and not by your federal level
which is the common European you know
well that's a very good point and and
Americans are amazed to see the European
Commission and the idea that there is
this body sitting in Brussels that is
telling the country's what to do which
would be unheard of in the u.s. I mean I
think it was it was part of the grand
bargain that was struck in the United
States in 1789 when our Constitution was
formed that we had started out with 13
colonies and in the American Revolution
the each of those colonies became a
state and and had very important
sovereign roles and so this grand
bargain was struck by the founding
fathers that each of the states now 50
of them have had major powers and and
can go off and do their own in many ways
the US Congress does have the authority
to preempt state law it's under the
Constitution Congress can do that but
the members of Congress are all elected
by their local constituencies many of
them used to be governors of their
states their local constituencies remain
very important and so Congress in the
environmental area has left a very
important role for the states and the
Clean Air Act is is one example of that
and so here you see states with
radically different policies
California's policy and the policy of
Texas are much different and that's okay
that's allowed
so states had their own ability to
impose taxes and here with the Regional
Greenhouse Gas Initiative for example
these ten states from the Northeast got
together and they decided they were
going to impose this charge on the
electric utilities operating in that
area so the ten states assess the
charges against the electric utilities
the electric utilities pay in the money
and the federal government has nothing
to do about it
that's a very good question and the
answer to that question is it has done
very little to reduce the emissions of
carbon dioxide because the price is so
low the price is so low that it does not
provide an incentive to companies to
reduce their emissions it has generated
several hundred million dollars which
the states have received and most of
that money has been put into energy
efficiency programs and renewable energy
not all of it some of it has been
grabbed by the state's to fill in their
budget deficit but most of it has gone
to to energy efficiency and renewable
energy experience in these programs
sorry to interrupt I think it's
culturally important for us step aside
on that question for a second if you go
back to top field first reaction when
came here to study you know jail system
you come to study democracy in America
studies
you realize that the critical system and
the legal system in the recognition
system had always a legitimacy from the
grassroots from the bottom and that
things would go up to a higher level
only only if it is more effective
efficient and would make sense to go up
at a higher and and everything you would
get in the presentation today doing
yours and enemas professorship you also
began I think start to grab how the
logic things are are just pile up so
differently so this this is the first
day but it is really important there is
a language issue but there's a
conceptual issue which is taking place
for recipe is the way this is presented
comes from and implicit federal liberal
and democratic structure which is far
different from what we experience in
Europe and you are made by grasso I
don't know we also made I crossover in
many ways absolutely but I mean put the
French which is a nation-state very
centralized for the British I would say
to you know centralization is like
breathing it's normal you know that's
the way things should happen and here
it's not it's certainly not and you
really have the feeling sometimes that
the more you go in the governmental body
the higher you go the more the American
people at the feeling that the power is
confiscated by people and that somewhat
is sort of for I need to revenge
Washington is he's almost like was the
power of Britain you know before the in
the band something very remote so I
think this is will we'll get back to
that in our session in our discussions
but that's really an important step in
your presentation that I wanted to
really emphasize I think it really
matters more intense them well that's
that's a very good point and in recent
years many politicians running for some
you don't you agree it was a comment
well we don't agree with your comment
okay I mean well so whilst the details
of the system might be different I think
the sentences are very very similar
there's a feeling that centralized power
is not necessarily a positive thing when
you sit in an ocean state it's very
uncomfortable they're very uncomfortable
feeling to have the centralized power of
courses overs and I expect it's very
similar if you sit at state level and I
know you do the federal system I think
there are lots of similarities but the
same factory coming the only way 50 plan
but really is somebody up over many
people working I mean I think we can do
this any faster that much as we want
so
just to make here we know is just to
your first comment no comment I was not
making any judgment on one way or not
I'm just commenting on something which
is very profound here that we need to
look at it take you to account if you
want to really grab otherwise it's
really complicated for us here I
complete anything I can guarantee you
now the sentiment and how British people
perceive they have to guess that is the
point out that is opposed to introduce
additional readies oh because they
don't believe
what we can want to thank allah i think
that the year in europe we will accept
Russians only to the extent that it
creates positive results there was a lot
of hope the climate regulation this
extent right then create results not
only loss of competitiveness so this
after a number of years we don't see the
positive that that will be a strong is
there concern that the ETS has reduced
the competitiveness of Europe factors to
run windows are firm in the UK were
proposing to put a minimum carbon
pricing the EU ETS is an especially high
enough level there is a mandated UK
government level the the backlash of
that from UK heavy industry has been
phenomenal so for example CBI
Confederation of British industry has
specifically stated that this is not
good for energy intensive British
business because it make it
uncompetitive and so currently what
looking at is potential carve-outs but
precisely the industries that you want
to regulate because you don't have an
effective multilateral regime in place
and it's exactly the same debate in the
u.s. of course and the u.s. is extremely
concerned about our competitiveness with
China and all of the many of the
regulations are being criticized by for
making us less competitive with China
the waxman-markey bill the bill that the
House of Representatives passed in
January that didn't finally become law
had many carve outs for what we're
defined as trade sensitive industries
such as steel and aluminum where there
was a real concern that this industry
and the jobs it creates would would go
to other places including China so it's
very much the same debate and of course
the issue of whether you should have
more centralized government less
centralized government is central to our
debate between the left and the right
between the Democrats and the
Republicans you've probably heard about
the Tea Party and so the which you could
call bit being at the far toward the far
right and they don't want the federal
government regulating anything and so it
major major debates here which I guess
play out throughout Europe and the US
ok which links the foreign direct
investment discussion this morning
specifically one of the main opponents
of the UK specific part legislation is
tatis fear and they're saying that the
UK will be made the UK steel industry
will be made uncompetitive compared to
Europe yet Tata as a major production
operation
it's how the foreign direct investment
is actually influencing policy even
though they're based in india right even
what the ownership is in any broker but
if they acquired former british steel'
so they have and they have what used to
be chorus which was the students that's
interesting so let me let me go on to
the US environmental regulations that
affect the electric power industry other
than greenhouse gas emissions and here
for the most part these are federal
regulations all the states could be more
stringent if they wanted to but very few
of them have stepped into any of these
areas the first concerns hazardous air
pollutants a large portion of the
mercury emissions in the US come from
burning coal since mercury is a
contaminant in a lot of coal and so EPA
has issued a has proposed a number of
regulations under the clean air act to
regulate mercury and arsenic and acid
gas and a number of other air pollutants
from stationary sources such as power
plants EPA issued its proposals this
past May the final rule is supposed to
be issued in November we'll see what
happens we'll see if they stay on that
schedule or whether that's delayed then
there is a rule called the transport
rule which really has it's a confusing
name it really concerns ozone and
certain other pollutants which are
present in elevated quantities in the
eastern United States so EPA has been
trying for several years to regulate
sulfur dioxide
I and nitrogen oxide emissions in those
states and they failed because of some
legal reasons they've come out now with
with a new set of regulations it's
called the cross-state air pollution
rule issued in August that limits sulfur
dioxide and nitrogen oxide emissions
from about 1,000 electric power plants
in the u.s. so that issue that that has
gone forward and it creates basically a
trading program within each of the
states that states that that emit errs
of these pollutants can can trade
emissions rights within the state and
they may also meet their requirement
their limitations by switching fuels or
installing other controls so each state
is given a limitation on its emissions
and and the emissions within that state
have to stay within this limitation
which which is a declining number but
within the state the companies have
flexibility and trading between
themselves or in switching fuels or
imposing pollution controls EPA was
working on changing the national ambient
air quality standards for ozone and let
me just back up and explain a little bit
that under the Clean Air Act EPA issues
national ambient air quality standards
for the most important air pollutants
and then it's the job of the states to
this to figure out how to reduce those
levels within those states EPA issues
these standards based on a lot of
scientific studies about what level of
air pollution is unhealthy so that the
you always have less than that EPA has
for several years been considering
reducing the ozone standard tightening
the standard for ozone and several
scientific studies have shown that that
many lives would be saved by doing that
just about two months ago President
Obama told EPA to stop that President
Obama directed EPA to with to put on
hold its plans to tighten the ozone
standard and everyone acknowledges that
the reason he did that was because of
all the resistance from the Republicans
to EPA regulation the environmentalists
of course we're very unhappy with that
they have filed several lawsuits which
are now in the courts and and we'll see
what happens but but the fact that
President Obama did that for the ozone
standards may mean that he will do that
for other important and very expensive
standards that are that are coming out
so EPA is is trying to to go forward but
they've been limited the head of EPA
Lisa Jackson is a an appointee of the
president and so she has to do what he
tells her to do there were rumors that
when he issued that order she thought
about resigning but she's still there
and so of course we don't have a
parliamentary system they're not they're
not members of Congress but they're put
their presidential appointees another
very important pending EPA regulation
concerns cooling water from power plants
a me a different federal law the Clean
Water Act gives EPA the authority to
issue lots of regulations to protect the
waters the and the fish and other
organisms that live in the waters one
problem that the that
exists in a number of rivers and lakes
is the is cooling water discharges the
heat is bad for the fish and the other
aquatic organisms and so EPA has been
considering a rule that could require
not only new power plants to install
cooling towers or other methods of
cooling the water before it cuts into
the water but might also require some of
the older plants to retrofit to install
cooling towers this of course is
enormously expensive and the electric
power industry is very much opposed to
it EPA is now going through this process
under a US law called the Administrative
Procedure Act whenever a federal agency
like EPA wants to issue a regulation it
has to first issue a draft of the
regulation and invite public comment and
then consider all those comments before
it issues the final regulation and after
it issues the final regulation people
can sue they can go to court to
challenge these regulations so this
happens with virtually every important
EPA regulation and and and and EPA is
now deciding what to do about cooling
water discharges from power plants we
don't know what the outcome will be
sometimes
question yes I was to build a new
facility assessment
with a force
I
this authorization facilities what level
of forces that new new facility games
the battle of a retro fitting is it is a
new standard said build new I guess in
California quite tricky to build without
authority all the parts of the status
what what's this immediate level of
quiet standards it would depend in part
on the status of the waters that the
where the plant would be located whether
the whether the particular plant would
have to negative and impact on the fish
and other aquatic resources of the
receiving river yes well the greenhouse
gas emissions are a little different
because they have a global impact and
the greenhouse gas impacts don't vary
from one place to another but the water
emissions that the water impacts do vary
so that would mostly be a state-level
decision on whether to require cooling
towers in the US but it is much more
likely that a new power plant would have
to have cooling towers then that an old
power plant would have to retrofit them
well I think a desulphurization a
requirement might be imposed because
there are already stringent sulfur
dioxide emissions limitations and in
1990 congress amended the Clean Air Act
to impose an acid rain an acid rain
program and under the acid rain program
there are significant limitations on
sulfur dioxide emissions from power
plants so yes I think that any new
coal-fired power plant would require
desulphurization autoregulation the
enforcement side coming form is that the
u.s. if i were to broke the rules and
exceed five authorized permits
it's about it's in between in that in
the in the u.s. we have something called
Citizen suits and that means that if a
facility like a power plant violates its
permit that the citizen citizens can go
to court themselves you know at first
the government has the first chance but
if the government does not bite then
citizens can go to court and they can
obtain a court order to the plant to
clean up and significant fines can be
imposed and the citizens get paid their
attorneys fees and so that's an
important incentive
and so in the 1970s there was a great
deal of that kind of litigation on water
pollution because every hole every
factory with the water potion permit has
to file a monthly report called a
discharge monitoring report with showing
what its water pollution discharges are
and comparing it to the permit and and
so citizens would then people went into
that business of filing citizen suits
they would get the discharge monitoring
report and they would compare it to the
permit and if there was a permit
violation they would sue and they would
always win and they would get their
attorneys fees and it's a very nice way
to make a living no and a class action
would not be helpful here I use a class
action as a way for many people to sue
if there are individual money damages
that you have and let's say you have a
million people each of whom suffered
five dollars in damage then it makes
sense to bring a class action but that
is seldom the case in the environmental
area here what the what the attorneys
want is the they want punishment of the
company and fees for themselves
because people suffering damage but with
the individuals have to show that they
themselves personally got sick yeah they
work well well that's a big difference
between big shaker being exposed to the
water lots of people can show that they
were exposed it's much harder to show
you because of the exposure and so is it
both affects more than
I see well so we only have class at in
class actions you have to show you
you're injured not just exposed so we
had these cooling water regulations that
are coming out another important set of
regulations that are now being
considered by EPA concerned the disposal
of coal ash as some of you may know in
November of 2008 there was a major spill
at a Tennessee Valley Authority facility
in Tennessee and it's build a large
quantity of of coal ash that had been
held in an impoundment and and destroyed
many acres of farmland and had a lot of
other effects it was a major news story
it was on television 60 minutes did a
major program on it and so forth coal
ash is not heavily regulated so far and
so it is lawful for a utility company to
store the coal ash behind an impoundment
they're obligated to make sure it's safe
but they otherwise they don't have to
take too many precautions after this
spill in Tennessee almost three years
ago there was a great deal of
controversy and many people said that
coal ash should be regulated like
hazardous waste that there are certain
pollutants that are in the ash and
because of those pollutants it's
dangerous the US has a law called the
resource conservation and Recovery Act
Rick rub which is our major law on
hazardous waste the handling of a
hazardous waste is much more stringent
than the rules on them then has handling
an ordinary waste and of course there
are similar laws in Europe so the the
issue that EPA is now considering is
whether to
to leave kool ass ash regulation as it
is now which is unlikely or to regulate
it like hazardous waste which would make
it far more expensive or to come up with
something in between I think most people
think that they are likely to come up
with in something in between they won't
require it to be handled in the same way
that dioxin or some some other really
dangerous chemical would be handled but
they won't just let it as it is so so
these regulations are now being
considered by EPA and no one knows
exactly how that is supposed to come out
meanwhile as you can see there are a
large number of these pending
regulations that could affect the
electric utility industry in a major way
so there's a major controversy now a
major dispute about the effect that all
of these regulations if they were to
take effect will have on the reliability
of the electric system in the u.s. there
are many an industry who are saying that
as a result of these rules many of the
existing generating facilities will shut
down because it's too expensive to
comply with these new rules others are
saying no that won't happen the power
plants that may shut down are getting
very old and are already on economic and
probably would be shut down anyway so
that that's a major battle right now and
you have
the cost of these these additional
proportion of these additional costs
might might be paid for by the customer
absolutely and they cost will be paid by
but by with the the bidding system for
electric dispatch the more expensive
companies won't be able to plants won't
be able to sell their power because it
will be too expensive and because of the
operation of the electricity markets and
the bidding system that before we have
the Sun Sun will be placed yes actually
and with many of them it's so expensive
that they will only be able to sell
their power during the peak periods and
so they'll still operate but but only
they'll still stay alive but only a few
hours a year will they be able to sell
their power but that of course doesn't
work if you have to install a cooling
tower because the cooling towers they're
all around the year and suddenly what
would be here so so that right so yeah
they aid to an old plant having to spend
half a billion dollars or something like
that on a cooling tower is probably
going to turn it to cause it to shut
down and so that's one of the major
that's one of the major fights
EPA has a large staff of scientists who
do a lot of studies and the scientists
conclude that these regulations are
needed to protect public health of the
environment and they're very influential
within the agency now now Lisa Jackson
the current head of the US EPA is
herself a scientist who came who was a
career epa employee that's an exception
very most of the heads of EPA had not
been career input and they're all
political in that they're all appointed
by the president but most of them came
in from our former governors or
something like that but but Lisa Jackson
was a career employee and so EPA has a
very strong internal culture of wanting
to protect health and the environment as
its own scientists see that now one very
important development in the regulation
of electric utilities is that several
months ago Michael Bloomberg who is not
only the mayor of New York City but is
also the richest person in New York City
because he found it and owns most of
Bloomberg media announced that he was
donating 50 million dollars of his own
personal money to the Sierra Club which
is a leading us environmental
organization for its project to try to
stop the construction of any new
coal-fired power plants and to shut down
existing coal-fired power plants that's
the purpose of this 50 million dollars
and a lot of it is going to go to
lawyers and to scientists and others who
are going to be fighting all of these
power plants
all across the country the construction
of new coal-fired power plants in the US
has slowed down tremendously in fact
there hasn't been a new start on
construction on a new coal-fired power
plant since 2009 now that's probably
mostly because of the declining price of
natural gas but the environmental
regulations and the the existing
conventional environmental regulations
and the uncertainty over greenhouse gas
regulations and the economic recession
and all of these factors have combined
so the Sierra Club and other
environmental groups think they have
mostly won that battle they have the
objective of not allowing any new
coal-fired power plants in the US and so
they have moved on to try to shut down
the existing coal-fired power plants
they know that they will not be able to
shut down all of them and the u.s. still
relies on coal for about half of its
electricity but they want to shut down
as many as they can and so they're going
to be filing lawsuits and appearing
before the state environmental agencies
and appearing before the state public
utility Regulatory Commission's to fight
them on air pollution on cooling water
on ash on their rate increase requests
on every other way that they can fight
these plants so this is going to be a
major battle and this 50 million dollar
donation from Mayor Bloomberg is really
unprecedented and is going to
really create it's an enormous amount of
funding for these environmental
organizations and it's going to be
leading to a lot of fights in the u.s.
his motivation is public health he know
well that's kind of a difficult question
he know but he wasn't supposed to be
able to run again last time either and
and he he's a he's a I don't think he's
doing it for re-election I think he it's
because people in New York City don't
care about it that much if it were just
reelection he would put the 50 million
dollars and he has so much money he
doesn't you know 50 million dollars to
him is nothing but I think you know he
found it he's the funder of a school of
public health in Baltimore he's the
leader of the effort to ban smoking in
New York and he's given a lot of money
to anti-smoking campaigns in New York
that's what he believes and I think that
that's what what is driving it
in any public in a public facility or in
a baseball stadium no I yeah it's a
matter of fact I think now you can but
the University Senate is about to
consider a regulation to ban it
everywhere on campus but they won't do
it this week they won't do it this week
that's right but that's a that's a major
controversy that that's going on I know
that on Wednesday I think you're going
to hear a presentation from professor
Klaus Lackner about carbon capture and
sequestration let me just say word about
what's happening legally with carbon
capture and sequestration and professor
lackner will tell you all about the
technology and what is happening that is
mostly a matter of state regulation
there are for the most part very minimal
federal regulations on carbon capture
and sequestration US EPA did announce a
few months ago that it was not going to
regulate this as a hazardous waste and
they're coming out with regulations
under another law called the Safe
Drinking Water Act two for some
regulations but more important
regulations are coming out at the at the
state level and and there are a lot of
issues about the ownership of the pore
space of the the space within the
subsurface rocks where the gas would go
so there are different states that are
coming out with different rules but one
area where the states do play a major
role is the question of recovery of the
costs of these experiments from
ratepayers American Electric Power
add a major pilot test going on in West
Virginia to try to build a carbon
capture and sequestration unit on one of
its coal-fired power plants but they
shut it down about two months ago
because they concluded that the state
electric utility commission would not
allow them to recover the costs of this
experiment from the ratepayers that it
would have to be paid for by their
shareholders and they didn't want that
and so they shot at that we saw the same
thing happen in other states meanwhile
the federal government has put a lot of
money into carbon capture and
sequestration research but there was a
pilot program in Illinois called future
gen which was shut down under President
Bush so there are a lot of legal
difficulties that have arisen I think if
the technology you know gets further
along and if we have greenhouse gas
regulations then we'll see more laws
that are favorable to it but right now
it has it has a lot of difficulties let
me now talk about a few things that are
going on with the federal energy
regulatory commission ferc which used to
be called the federal Power Commission
and it's the major federal agency on
electricity regulation one thing that
they've done is in July they issued a
major order called order number 1000
which is called the final rule on
transmission planning and cost
allocation by transmission owning and
operating public utilities let me also
say that I easy name right there their
materials on this and all of the other
regulations that I'm talking about that
I guess we're posting on the website for
the conference you'll be able to see
summaries of these but but the basic
idea here is a concern
the transmission grid which is heavily
regulated by FERC and its design and and
one of the purposes of this rule is to
make it easier for new companies to go
into the electric transmission business
that it had been that whenever there was
a proposal for a new transmission line
the existing utility companies had a
right of first refusal that they could
they were the first people with the
option to build a new line this
regulation eliminates that the
regulation also says that factors of
public policy can be considered in the
government decision about what new an
electric transmission line should be
built and where they should go and I
think what they're mostly talking about
here is to encourage transmission lines
that will make it easier for wind and
solar and other renewable sources to
gain access to the grid and maybe this
is less clear to make it more difficult
for lines that would serve coal-fired
power plants it's not clear whether
that's going to be a factor but
certainly the encouragement of renewable
energy sources is going to is going to
be a major factor the regulation also
has very elaborate rules on cost
allocation on who pays for the
construction of these lines
you can just explain a bit separate
different states that stuff when you go
physically look at the mission well the
basic law in the u.s. is that FERC the
federal agency sets wholesale electric
rates and it makes decisions on
interstate citing each state sets retail
electric rates and decides on what lines
will be cited within the state so that
that there's always a lot of tension
about which is federal in which is state
and then there are some federal statutes
that called for the formation of things
called regional transmission
organizations rtos which are which have
the job of ensuring that helping to
ensure that the electricity system is
reliable and they can tell electric
utilities that they have to build and
somebody has to build a new line in a
particular area so those are very
powerful entities and so each state is
subject to all these rules with the
single exception again of Texas and and
Texas is mostly I don't know if you
heard about that
Texas has mostly disconnected itself
from the rest of the country they
generate their own electricity they
transmit it within the state there are
there's very little transmission
capacity between Texas and the other
states and and therefore they're largely
independent and since they're self
contained that are not subject to
federal regulation in the same way that
the rest of the country is well
politically you know they're the biggest
state other than Alaska they think
differently than many other parts of the
country
I don't think so yeah they're a state
like everybody else they may not accept
that well legally what they did is they
organized their electric system so
they're not subject to FERC authority by
being isolated which is which is very
unusual but they're happy with it and so
so they're the exception but everybody
else is is subject to it and you have
all these regional transmission
organizations around the country that
that help dictate when power lines are
built that has only been operating for
the last several years and people think
that it still needs a lot of a lot of
reforms there was also a law passed to
try to allow federal preemption if a
state was going to slowly and allowing
the transmitted the construction of a
new transmission line there was a law
that allowed FERC to go in and override
it and to preempt state authority that
has not been very effective and so there
now efforts to try to
to strengthen that federal authority
another important set of rules that FERC
is now developing is on integration of
renewables into the into the system to
make it easier for generators of wind
and solar and other renewable energy to
tie into the the grid and to sell their
power and obviously there's a major
issue that's wind and solar are
intermittent and the Sun doesn't always
shine and the wind doesn't always blow
so there are different characteristics
that make it harder for them to sell
electricity into the system and so FERC
is working on finding ways to make that
easier there are also they also issued a
recent rule on on paying for demand
response as you know with demand
response a large consumer of electricity
agrees with the power company not to not
to use electricity during peak periods
and they get an economic benefit for it
so FERC has new regulations on how that
is paid for and is designed so that a
consumer of electricity is paid as much
for agreeing to it to a demand response
program as the electric company would
pay to buy electricity from a generator
and so that's that's an important new
rule that that has been issued and there
are also a great many rules that are
being issued now on the smart grid on
trying to encourage that and a lot of
federal research-and-development money
is going into development of more Smart
Grid technologies the final item on my
agenda let me just say a few words about
what's happening with
nuclear technology in the US and what's
happening with shale gas extraction in
the u.s. so as you all know no nuclear
no new nuclear power plants have been
ordered in the United States since the
three mile island accident of 1979 so we
have all of the nuclear power plants we
have operating in the United States
which is about 100 of them are getting
old and are approaching relicensing
there are a lot of fights going on
around the United States about whether
to allow the relicensing' of these power
plants the most prominent of these
fights is going on here in New York with
the Indian Point nuclear power plant
which is located about 30 miles north it
here there are two operating units now
they're on the banks of the Hudson River
and the governor of New York State
andrew Cuomo has announced that he
thinks that Indian Point should not be
relicensed and that it should be shut
down this is an area where the states
have only limited authority nuclear
power is one of the areas where there is
federal preemption for obvious reasons
you don't want states making certain
decisions about nuclear materials but
the states still do have some authority
and one of the areas where they have
authority is cooling water and so the
state of New York is now demanding that
Entergy which owns Indian Point now
install cooling towers for the Indian
Point nuclear power plant as a condition
of its being relicensing so there are
hearings that are about to start these
are formal hearings in front of the New
York State Department of Environmental
Conservation on whether the state is
going to
acquire energy to build new cooling
towers for these plants and energy is
very actively opposing that and we'll
see what happens but Governor Cuomo
clearly wants that plan to shut down his
father Mario Cuomo was the governor of
New York State 20 years ago and as many
of you know governor Mario Cuomo was
responsible for shutting down the
Shoreham nuclear power plant that had
been built by the Long Island lighting
company and and the Shoreham plant never
achieved full commercial operation it
was completely built and it generated a
few kilowatts and a pilot test but of
the state required it to shut down and
so obviously that was an extremely
expensive decision at that loko it's
been five or six billion dollars
building that power plant that it
couldn't use and it led to very high
electric rates on Long Island and the
reorganization of lil co and so forth so
I don't know whether it's something in
the Cuomo family genes but they don't
like they don't like nuclear power
plants different parts of the country
different states have much different
attitudes in some of the southern states
they are all in favor of nuclear power
so there there are some active proposals
for new nuclear power plants in
Mississippi and Alabama and some other
places in the south and some of that may
proceed obviously the Fukushima disaster
has received a great deal of attention
and some of the people who had been in
favor of expanding nuclear power in the
US are having second thoughts about that
and certainly it's causing the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission our federal body
that regulates nuclear power to take a
new look at some of the safety standards
the design standards and the protections
against events of that sort quakes and
tsunamis and so forth so that's going to
be a major issue another major issue in
the u.s. right now is the is what to do
about spent nuclear fuel for a long time
the US policy was going to be to
reprocess spent nuclear fuel I know that
that's the way that it's used in France
but in 1974 after the explosion of some
nuclear weapons in the Indian
subcontinent the United States changed
its policy under President Ford and
President Carter and decided to stop
efforts to reprocess commercial spent
fuel and instead build a permanent
long-term geologic repository for the
spent fuel Congress passed a law to come
up with a location for this the site was
selected was called Yucca Mountain
Nevada and the United States spent
several billion dollars on the studies
and plans to build this repository at
Yucca Mountain and it hadn't received it
hadn't received a final license to build
it but last year President Obama
canceled the Yucca Mountain project and
many people think that a major reason he
did that is that a very there's a very
powerful united states senator named
harry reid from Nevada who didn't want
the plan so there's now litigation about
whether the administration had the power
to cancel the Yucca Mountain plant and I
don't know how it will turn out some
people think that the cancellation of
the of the Yucca Mountain project may be
rescinded and they will they make oh
back there's also now renewed talk of
reprocessing
but this is a very unsettled area in the
u.s. there's no clear US policy now and
what to do with spent fuel and obviously
that's a difficulty for the growth of
the nuclear industry if we don't have a
clear solution for what to do with spent
fuel for now it's it's almost all stored
on site at the plants where it's
generated but Fukushima showed there are
some perils with doing that over a long
term so we'll see what happens the final
thing I'll mention and we're almost out
of time is that of course that the most
important development in the energy
picture in the United States in the last
several years has been the development
of shale gas technology and hydro
fracking which is allowing large
quantities of natural gas to be
extracted in a way that is very
economical and that prior to this
hydraulic fracturing fracturing
technology was not available in this
technology has become very controversial
in some places in the US especially New
York in the last year or two the
controversy about hydro fracking has
become a very very prominent political
issue in New York most other parts of
the US are allowing it and so we're
seeing a lot of it in Pennsylvania and
Texas and elsewhere there's controversy
about water pollution impacts
principally there are some other issues
but it's mostly about water pollution
the regular the regulation of this
technology is mostly a state matter
there's very little federal regulation
of it and a lot of differences in the
ways that the different states regulate
it just a few weeks ago New York State
announced that it was going forward with
the idea of allowing
hydrofracking in many parts of the state
not all of the state but many parts of
this day many people think that one of
the reasons for that is Governor Cuomo
is so eager to shut down the Indian
Point nuclear power plant but he
realizes there has to be an alternative
source for the electricity that the
Indian Point plant now generates and
that is likely to be new new natural
gas-fired power plants and if you're
going to allow new net and natural
gas-fired power plants you probably
ought to allow someone to extract
natural gas for those plants so I don't
know but that may be one factor that
went into New York's decision and
another important factor is that in some
parts of New York State not here in
Manhattan but in upstate New York this
gas development seemed to be a major way
to generate new jobs and new local taxes
and so forth so a lot of political
support in some parts of the state in
opposition in other parts of the state
but clearly the new development of shale
gas is a is another major development in
the US energy picture